The Haunting vision of the New York City
skyline shrouded in Orange Haze on
Wednesday had subsided by Thursday but
officials in New York and New Jersey
still warmed of dangerous air quality
levels given the forecast for today we
continue to urge strongly all sensitive
individuals especially meaning those
with
health conditions like asthma
heart disease lung disease as well as
our kids pregnant individuals and
seniors all of the above especially to
stay inside overnight the haze had moved
southwards the Philadelphia Health
commissioner said that at one point the
city's air quality index hit 500 the
index only goes as far as 500. on
Thursday it was Washington DC to
experience the lack of visibility the
nation's landmarks barely visible for
much of the day Parks playgrounds the
National Zoo all closed it's weird yeah
it's a weird situation seems like it's
getting worse every summer so I hope we
do something about climate control
before too long
environmental scientists have long
warned that global warming will increase
the Heat and conditions necessary for
wildfires such as those raging in Canada
to spread out of control
firefighters are still battling hundreds
of blazes across the country a third of
them in Quebec in the East now even
people thousands of kilometers away of
feeling the effects President Joe Biden
released a statement that said that the
fires and spreading smoke were a stark
reminder of the impacts of climate
change and addressed the fires at a news
conference with British prime minister
Rishi sunak I spoke yesterday with prime
minister Trudeau
and I've decided uh dictated a National
interagency Fire Center
response to Canada's request for
additional firefighters and the fire
suppression assets such as air tankers
we already have 600 American
firefighters on the ground have been
there for a while in Canada including
Hot Shots and the smokejumper crews and
it's very important that affected
communities listen to the guidance of
their state and local officials just
last week Joe Biden and Congress
fast-tracked another gas pipeline
despite environmental concerns there
remains a gulp between what's said about
climate change here and what's actually
done Shabbat ANSI Al Jazeera Washington